every little thing you think that's me
every little thing you think that you
need every little thing that's just
feeding your greed you know I bet that
you'd be fine without me hello everybody
welcome to the minimalists podcast where
we discuss what it means to live a
meaningful life with less my name is
joshua fields Millburn and boy oh boy do
we have a treat for you today
today's episode is featuring our good
friend Colin right now for those of you
who don't know Colin we often refer to
him as the third minimalist we've gone
on a bunch of Tours with him
we started a publishing company with him
back in 2012 called asymmetrical press
and in fact Colin is the first person
who introduced me and thereby introduced
the minimalists to this thing called
minimalism it was about a month after my
mother died and my marriage ended I I
met Colin the same way we meet everyone
these days on Twitter and I saw this
tweet actually was a retweet from
someone that I was following and it was
something from Colin and he said he was
a minimalist and I didn't really know
what minimalism was and in context of
living in context of a lifestyle I mean
I knew about minimalism in terms of
literature and art and architecture but
what was this thing called minimalism
with respect to how one might live his
or her life and he said he was a
minimalist and and that allowed him to
pursue what he was passionate about and
then I really dug into his life and he
had some videos online and everything he
owned fit into a backpack in fact he
owned 52 items and I really admired that
but I certainly didn't desire to live
that same exact lifestyle I didn't want
to live out of a backpack
I enjoyed owning a kitchen table and a
desk to write at and certain things that
just wouldn't fit into my life or
certain things in my life that wouldn't
into the the Peripatetic writers life
that was Colin but this thing called
minimalism allowed him to pursue what he
was passionate about and and for Colin
that was travel he was just wildly
passionate about travel when he was in
his mid early to mid 20s he was
successful in a very narrow sense he ran
a branding and design studio in Los
Angeles and he was working over a
hundred hours a week I mean just this
amazing you know Puritan work ethic but
he wasn't satisfied he wasn't happy he
didn't feel fulfilled and he didn't feel
like he was pursuing what he was
passionate about he was making good
money but he left that all behind so he
could travel the world and he learned
how to travel to a new country every
four months and that's how I found out
about him as he was running this blog
called Exile lifestyle which you could
find at Exile lifestyle calm and he
didn't even pick where he was going to
travel to because he wanted a fresh
experience each time and so he basically
let his readers at his blog vote on
where he was going to go next and so
when I first connected with him on
Twitter I think he was in New Zealand
perhaps and he had just been in
Argentina and was headed to Iceland and
India and other places after that but
every four months he moved to a new
country based on the votes of his
readers and again not a lifestyle that I
wanted to lead obviously but I'd really
admired it because he was now focused on
what he was passionate about and how he
did that he got the excess stuff out of
the way and when he got the excess stuff
out of the way he started also getting
his priorities back into order well
colin has become a really good friend of
mine over the last six or so years like
I said we started a publishing company
with him and he is he just turned 30 not
long ago and he's published almost 33 or
34 books at this point I've lost count
and he's just a prolific writer a
phenomenal blogger he also has a great
youtube video series called consider
this and he just started a podcast and
it's called let's know things and you
can find that podcast wherever you get
your podcast you can
also find all the show notes over at
let's know things dot-com but I think
Colin is really intelligent and he's
very articulate and I'm just I feel
great that he finally has a podcast out
there because he's he's gonna use this
medium to do really wonderful things
it's a lot different from the typical
format that you hear from me and Ryan
where we tend to answer questions or
we'll banter back and forth he really
drills down into specific topics and we
selected a particular episode from his
podcast that is an unpublished episode
he's gonna let us use this today to
share with you it's an episode about
suburbia and how we can consider both
sides the good and the bad of suburban
living and really how I came about and
where do we go from here as a society
and so I really hope you enjoy this
podcast oh and one more thing just a
quick note before we get started for
those of you who are interested in
improving your writing whether that's
writing emails writing the next great
American novel
or just improving your writing for your
blog I have a one-day Writing Workshop
it's a couple hours long coming up later
this month there's still a few seats
left of that you get you can find all
the details over at how to write better
dot-org all right Joe I hope you enjoyed
this episode with Cullen rate it's from
his podcast let's know things and it is
called suburbia enjoy
I grew up in the suburbs here in the
u.s. first in the Bay Area and then in
the Midwest both cases were surprisingly
similar the yards in Missouri were much
bigger than they were in California but
we still lived in neighborhoods removed
from economic activity my entire world
was accessible you didn't wander into
the neighbors yards perhaps but you
might walk through them or there might
be the neighbor with the yard that was
just the right size for playing football
with the other neighborhood kids and so
if they gave you permission you spent a
lot of your time there in both cases as
far as I could walk in any direction
there were just more houses they
sometimes varied in size or design maybe
there's that one offshoot Street where
all the rich people lived
they had swimming pools and such and the
other where maybe it's mostly folks who
make a little bit less money there was
some variety within the homogeny but
despite knowing the word suburbs as a
kid I never really took the time to
think about what it meant I guess I
supposed that everyone lived in a
situation much like mine though perhaps
in apartment buildings rather than
ranch-style homes with nearby parks
instead of yards with fences around them
the idea that you might be able to walk
out your door to a corner store or a
downstairs coffee shop never crossed my
mind
the suburban model has flourished but
it's not the standard everywhere you go
there are places with mixed types of
real estate and a greater amount of
publicly accessible geography there are
places where there's more diversity of
economic classes and cultural heritage
there are places that were built before
the actually quite recent suburban boom
and others that have been built in the
years sense as we've come to recognize
the downsides of such an organizational
system on this episode I want to talk
about suburbia and why so many people
believe that it sucks
you're listening to let's know things
I'm callin right
the starting point for today's episode
comes from a blog entitled likewise a
blog and the article itself is very
aptly named why suburbia
sucks now you can read the article to
read the 10 or so reasons that the
author believes that suburbia sucks
and these are very good reasons they are
a lot of the same reasons that many
developers use for why we should reduce
the suburbs and a lot of the same
reasons that individuals give when they
talk about why they want to move away
from the suburbs either into a more
rural situation or a more urban
situation but what are we talking about
when we talk about suburbs because I
think we probably all know the word
suburbs but even though you can picture
kind of what it is in your head it may
not be that you have a decent definition
for it I I certainly didn't know the
whole story before I started researching
for this episode when we talk about
suburbs we're actually talking about
something that started back in Roman
times
the Roman cities had suburbs little
walled cities that were outside of their
cities and they were essentially little
towns that orbited the larger cities and
kind of coasted off of those cities
economic wakes so what you do is work in
the city and then live in these little
walled settlements outside of the larger
city if you couldn't afford to live
within the city which sounds kind of
familiar right I mean that's that's what
suburbs are today they haven't always
looked like they look today but the
modern version of the suburb emerged in
the early 20th century in London and
London through a decent chunk of modern
history has been the most populated and
population dense cities in the world and
at the beginning of the 20th century in
particular it was considered to be
incredibly densely packed with people
and very filthy and scummy and what they
did is they completed a series of trains
that led outside of town and as a result
of these trains that were leading
outside of the city people found that
they could live further from the center
of all of that economic activity and
still make it into work each day and so
these forms of mass transit in
particular trains and Underground trains
enabled the birth of the modern suburb
now it also helped that at the time
England was recovering from World War
one and they were looking at their
people and they were looking at
particularly how unhealthy a lot of them
were from living under the conditions
that people were living in that the
lower-income people in particular we're
living in within the city and they
started romanticizing the day is back in
the day when they lived in cottages and
they lived in estates and they decided
that they were going to have to spread
out a little bit if they wanted to have
healthy young men who could afford to
defend them in times of conflict and so
the with the government's blessing
developers started building further and
further out and they built according to
a model that was more like those more
traditional English estates
rather than building a bunch of
apartment style buildings right up next
to each other and piling them on top of
each other they built more squat houses
and they built yards around them they
gave people lots of space in which to
play in which to participate in sport
and that would allow them to stay
healthy and strong around that same time
around just after World War one New York
and Boston had the biggest suburbs in
the world they were had already fleshed
out certain elements of their mass
transit systems and so they had these
sprawling cities and so they had
neighborhoods shooting off in every
which way that had access relatively
easy access to the center of town and
people would leave at the end of each
day after going to work to essentially
just go home and sleep before hopping on
the train again they considered these
homes in the suburbs to be little more
than just a place
go sleep at the end of actually living
your life for the day and so they spent
as little time there as possible
now that changed dramatically in the
United States around the world too but
particularly within the United States
after World War Two and a couple of
things conspired to make that happen
conspired to really blow the suburban
experiment up to the next extreme one of
those things was the veterans were
returning from overseas were returning
from wherever it was that they were
fighting and coming home and deciding
that they just wanted a quiet life they
wanted to chill the hell out for a bet
they wanted to relax they wanted to have
a nice home they wanted to have a front
porch they wanted to have a car in the
garage and they wanted to have a yard
where they could keep their dog or where
their kids could play they wanted
something simple they wanted the simple
life they didn't want to be around a
bunch of people and the noise of the
city and it just so happened that around
the same time the FHA the Federal
Housing Administration began to provide
loans for several different types of
people but for veterans in particular
and these loans essentially allowed them
to get houses and all the veterans had
to pay upfront was 1.75 percent of the
base amount of the loan and so most of
them could afford that so they started
scooping up houses left and right and
that fed the surge in development of
these suburban homes homes that were not
just places to go and sleep well you
spent most of your days in the city but
rather a place to go live you wanted to
just turn this place into a little slice
of heaven
another simultaneous development was the
completion of several skunkworks
projects including the Manhattan Project
which led to the development of the
atomic bomb these skunk work projects
which is just the term used for kind of
a project kept separate and in a lot of
cases secret from everybody else these
were developed in their own little towns
and as a result of being able to operate
these little towns
all of the people who worked on them
lived there essentially little planned
communities the government felt that
they had a much better understanding of
how to essentially build these
pre-planned communities that would allow
people to live in such a way that they
were both productive and happy but
primarily and this was something that
was largely unspoken except by the
people involved in the lead-up to the
Cold War they were also convinced that
in spreading out people in this way
removing people particularly people that
they considered to be vitally important
which were primarily scientists and
people with a lot of money and prestige
and such keeping them spread out and
away from cities would prevent a
potential enemy say somebody else that
had an atomic bomb from destroying a
great deal of our intellectual and human
infrastructure with one weapon the way
that we had when we dropped the bombs on
Hiroshima and Nagasaki so in an effort
to spread out our human wealth there
were a lot of different ways in which
the government not not necessarily
directly subsidized but certainly
supported and greased the wheels for the
expansion of the suburbs and then from
the mid-50s onwards there was the
further development the expansion of
something that we'd already started but
like a hardcore expansion of the
American highway system this highway
system was intended to connect the
cities and towns of the United States to
each other for purposes of trade but
also again there was that military
underpinning there was the desire to be
able to move around our weaponry and our
people and anything else that might be
important in case we were invaded or in
case we needed to invade somebody else
and move this equipment in these people
around very quickly and so the
development of the highway system served
the same purpose within the u.s. that
the trains and the Underground trains
served in London and in New York and
Boston they became kind of an
alternative to a master
system but something that allowed a far
greater diversity in living locations
for the people who wanted to work in
cities now the side effect of this the
sudden ability to live in these
different places and to live in these
ostensibly much more pleasant situations
places that were not so filthy and
crowded and loud places where you didn't
have perception-wise at least you didn't
have the the crime issues that you were
beginning to have in a lot of the cities
and then in addition to that perception
there was also the perception that was
popular then thankfully not as popular
now that all of these immigrants were
coming in and ruining our cities and
there was something called white flight
within the u.s. that essentially had a
lot of white people moving from urban
environments into the suburbs in an
attempt to get away from these different
colored people and these people with
different religions and different values
and so that certainly fed the
development of these communities as well
and later led to a lot of issues because
a lot of suburban areas were essentially
segregated if not officially some of
them officially but if not officially
certainly in practice because the boards
that regulated these areas and decided
who could move in wanted to keep them
pure and wanted to keep the
quote-unquote riffraff out and to them
again a very different time that was
people of different colors and religions
and so on and so that's one of the
original reasons that the suburban areas
became associated with cultural and
economic and in a lot of cases racial
homogeny a lot of these places were
perceived at least to be kind of like
country clubs where you were in or you
were out and if you weren't one of us we
don't want you to be here and we all
moved here to protect our kids to
protect our families and protection in
the way that that word was being used at
the time was protection from outside
influences and ideas dangerous things
and just to give you an idea of why at
that time we were looking at things our
enemies we had just finished
to war with fascists and the new enemy
was a group of Communists and a lot of
the tensions within the United States
were happening in the south and in urban
centers and they were racial tensions
and so anytime you have a triumvirate of
different influences different things to
be concerned about there are going to be
certain groups of people that with the
best intentions will look at that and
say okay I cannot even deal with this
and go flee and in this case they were
being encouraged on all sides
economically and by the government by
their own cultural perception you know
when your friends move there and then
your other friends move there then you
probably want to move there as well and
so this was an effect that was amplified
because there were so many different
variables contributing to it and this
ties into and feeds a lot of other
issues that are much bigger concepts
that I won't get into now maybe on a
future episode but the development and
the perpetuation of ghettos within the
United States for example were partially
the result of white flight and other
versions of it where certain elements of
an economic class start to move out and
then the incentive to screw people over
and not upkeep buildings and to keep
people segregated within certain parts
of town that effect is amplified and
leads to a lot of incredibly unfortunate
consequences but we touched on briefly
the idea of designed cities we had the
English that were looking out into all
of this open fields that they had and
realizing we've got a lot of open space
and we've got all of our people crammed
in these little tiny areas it's making
us incredibly unhealthy maybe we can do
it better and there was a very popular
movement for a little while there just
for a decade or two called the Garden
City movement that had very specific
ideas about the ideal living situation
in terms of how certain Gardens in
certain parks and certain streets should
all be laid out if you look it up it's
kind of like a Fung Shui for how to lay
out a city but very like a very British
version of that that was derived from
litter
rather than spirituality but they're not
the only ones to have stumbled upon or
developed the idea of pre-planned cities
and urban planning this is absolutely
something that was happening within the
United States but when you look at more
authoritarian governments but also in
particular governments that tend to have
5-year plans and that have more planned
economies as well the Soviet Union and
it's satellites States lots and lots of
pre-planned cities you look at China
today they've got a massive number of
pre-planned cities and they are of
massive scale the unfortunate thing and
we saw it back then within the Soviet
Union and we see it today
in places like Phoenix Arizona in the
United States where we just over built
these crazy pre-planned communities and
then you see all of the massive ghost
towns the ghost metropolis is in China
is that we end up planning using theory
here's the theory of how people will
live what they will want where they will
go what path would be most convenient
for them in theory but in reality and
when it comes down to feet hitting the
pavement an actual use day-to-day these
places just don't perform the way that
they should a good analogy to this is
another element of the Soviets pre
planned economy where they were
determining how many nails they would
need how many paper clips how many
things like that basics that they would
need every year and they'd say okay we
need two million nails this year well of
course I mean there's no way to know no
reliable way to know how many nails you
will use in a year and they had constant
shortages of some things and constantly
overproduced other things as a result
well the same is true typically within
pre-planned cities and towns and
suburban areas the things that look very
good on paper and that seemed to fit the
data and that seemed to fit historical
precedent very seldom survived people
moving in because as soon as people move
in then reality takes hold and they
realize oh this one thing missed
and that impacts that and that impacts
this and it kind of reverberates out of
control all of these little things add
up and add up and add up and eventually
these places become either incredibly
unpleasant or people start moving out or
different sorts of people start moving
in than the people they initially
planned there's a lot of different ways
for the land value to drop then as a
result or for people to default on the
loans that they took out and what we end
up with then is a situation kind of like
in Phoenix as I mentioned before where
we had all of these subdivisions that
were built in the middle of nowhere and
they were gorgeous and really well made
but nobody wanted them because they
forgot to build this one thing or
because it didn't have this other thing
or they didn't have easy access to the
place they wanted to go and so we built
our own ghost towns beautiful ghost
towns in a lot of cases to these
pre-planned communities are built for a
particular purpose or priority but not
necessarily for the inhabitants
priorities and a lot of cases these
priorities might be consumption it might
be that they build the communities
around a mall or a shopping center and
it makes perfect sense because a lot of
this development was actually spurred
and then supported by and amplified by
the concept of the American dream and
the American dream for the purposes of
this conversation there's a lot that
goes into it part of it was that having
your own home in your own yard and a
two-car garage and a wife and
two-and-a-half kids but part of it too
is the idea of McMansions which is the
natural progression of that idea if
having a home and two cars in the garage
is somebody's dream well if I'm as
awesome as I think I am that means I
need a bigger one I need four cars in
the garage
I need a much bigger lawn and as these
homes and as the lawns and as the number
of garages that you have on your home
increases the desire to fill those
spaces also increase and we end up with
a huge consumption problem that we still
struggle with today this is not
something that's been solved
unfortunately even very
all homes tend to have a lot of wasted
space it's something like 40% of our
homes we actually use regularly and the
rest is just wasted space that we're
paying rent for and that we're cleaning
and that were storing stuff in because
we don't want empty space that looks
weird and so we buy stuff to fill up
that space and so city planning takes us
into account if they're gonna give us
great big spaces they're going to put us
next to places where we can buy things
to put in those empty spaces and then
perhaps the most troublesome thing about
these pre-planned cities and suburbs is
that they fail to account for any type
of growth or change or evolution not
just in the number of people there but
in global infrastructure and technology
they they fail to account for a surge of
people and an influx and the desire to
maybe continue extending in a certain
direction and as a result you end up
with suburbs that have very high
population densities just like the
cities the people that are trying to
escape or maybe you end up with another
suburb built next door that's newer and
shinier and a slightly higher end and
then your suburb decreases in value as a
result but then consider things like
telephones landlines as a result of the
mobile phone revolution in the internet
revolution we have all of these phone
booths all over the world that are just
sitting there not completely useless in
certain elements of society but we
certainly don't need as many of them as
we have now and there's things like this
everywhere within society things that at
the moment were vitally important but
when we develop past them when we come
up with something new we end up with all
of this antique infrastructure that we
can either keep and continue to upkeep
at great expense and increasingly
greater expense as the rest of the world
moves on to other things and the parts
and components and know-how that we need
becomes more and more in demand or we
pay an exorbitant amount of money to
replace it all to take out all the phone
booths to take out all of this type of
cable to run a new type of cable start
building with different materials
because we found out asbestos causes
cancer
there's a lot of these issues that
emerge over time and unfortunately most
planned communities do not take this
into account they tend to be beautiful
dioramas representing a very particular
point in time but their viability
long-term is very much in question and
that's something that we're seeing a
whole lot today for multiple reasons now
one of the changes that were beginning
to see today is that for the first time
since like 1950 people are moving toward
urban areas rather than away from them
in 1950 I think was the year that for
the first time ever more people lived in
suburbs in the United States than cities
and since then pretty much up until the
last decade or so that's been the case
but in the last decade or so there's
been some major changes all different
types of reasons that people are moving
there but a lot of them tie back to this
one idea and it's it's the difference
between car scale and people scale and
if you look at the US a lot of the East
Coast was developed early on this was
stuff that was built out and fleshed out
in the age of horse-and-buggy and in the
age of trains but the further west you
go the more likely you are to see cities
that were developed in the time of the
automobile and LA is a perfect example
of this it is just a car hell you you
cannot get around without owning a car
there except for downtown and a lot of
other cities are like that as well and
it makes perfect sense you know when
these cities were built cars were the
bomb cars were the thing that everybody
was investing in we had no reason to
believe that the car boom would ever
subside and we were building out the
super highway system and the dice were
rolled and everything was coming up car
and as a result we ended up building our
cities we ended up building our suburbs
we ended up building everything in car
scale and that means that it doesn't
matter if you can walk to a grocery
store if you can drive there that's
close enough when you leave your home it
doesn't matter that you can't get
anywhere just by walking because you're
gonna get in your car anyway this city
was built for the car so this effect
convenience issues like that but even
the city itself even the look and feel
of it is based on a car rather than a
human being
we need these great big avenues and
thoroughfares and streets because we're
prioritizing car traffic over a
pedestrian traffic and you can
definitely feel that difference if you
try to walk down a street in Phoenix
Arizona compared to walking down a
street in Paris you see the difference
immediately
a people scale city is shaped and
proportioned for a human being without a
car around them and that tends to feel
quite a bit more comfortable and this is
something that we're gravitating toward
significantly more than we were back in
the 50s 60s 70s 80s 90s we were still
romanticizing the car then and there's a
big push back against that idea now that
we've seen the downsides of these
pre-planned suburban areas and and the
the commute economy to begin with I mean
suburbs were built because of the
commute they were built to allow people
to have affordable housing while still
working in the city and today for a lot
of people the idea of getting in your
car and driving for however long it
takes you to get to work simply doesn't
make sense anymore
now something often attributed to the
myriad variables that go into something
being car scale or people scale is that
these planned organized separated areas
tend to be quite sterile and identity
lists because if you break them all
apart and you put where people live
separate from where they live like you
you have their homes separate from where
they go to get a drink separate from
where they go to work separate from
where they go to meet up with friends
then you don't get the shared culture
between those areas you tend to lack the
unpredictability and unpredictability is
valuable to the creative process you
don't accidentally run into people on
the way to and from work because you're
getting in your car you end up
instilling a sense of homogeny to all
these different places
so every workplace begins to look like
every other workplace every place where
you go to sleep begins to look like
every other place where you go to sleep
there's no cross-pollination between
these different cultures because we've
built everything bento box like so that
it has its own little compartment and in
a lot of cases the way these areas are
planned out to begin with are planned by
technocrats it's planned by people who
are higher up and so they don't
necessarily understand the needs of the
people the working-class man and woman
who are living in these places and so
everything begins to look griddle
everything begins to look like something
you can put on a spreadsheet and when it
comes to people and how they live and
what makes them happy and fulfilled
that's almost never the case you look at
a lot of places around the world that do
this on an epic scale you look at
Singapore is a great example of this
it's a city-state so it's like five
million people that live in one city and
that's their entire country and it has
for its entire existence been predicated
on incredibly rational organizational
principles and some of these have worked
really well they've done incredibly well
in certain ways but a lot of people even
Singapore's biggest fans I quite enjoyed
Singapore and I feel this way they feel
that it is quite sterile and it is
something that lacks a little bit of its
own vibe most cities of a scale of 5
million people feel like something
specific you can go into that city and
say oh this feels like New York or this
feels like LA this feels like Paris this
feels like London this feels like Hong
Kong but in Singapore it just feels like
it's a place and there's a lot of people
and there's food and there's places to
live and it feels incredibly practical
but it doesn't feel like any happy
accidents ever occur it feels like
everything is planned out to the nth
degree
there are of course pros and cons to
that lots of pros I would argue but but
the cons tend to outweigh the pros for a
lot of people because in terms of
quality of life if
your priorities are to make some money
and be perfectly safe from any perceived
threat that type of really well
orchestrated really well planned
community could be very appealing but I
think most people's priorities deviate
from those two things substantially
there are a lot of different efforts to
plan for the same vibe that you would
find in an unplanned location
pre-planned cities pre-planned suburbs
places like that to try to make them
feel as if they're not planned so
they're trying to avoid feeling like
Singapore and trying to feel more like
Brooklyn where you have something that
kind of grows willy-nilly and it's
considered like a bad place to live and
then it flourishes culturally and
becomes like a cool new spot that
everybody wants to go and becomes too
expensive for anybody else to live there
there's actually apparently a pretty
extreme effort by some investment banks
to invest in a lot of the same types of
businesses that typically spring up
right before a city or a town or a
suburb area has a Brooklyn moment when
people start to perceive it as being
very cool and all the prices on
everything goes up and it starts to feel
like something very unique and so
they'll go into a town and they'll buy
up as much real estate as possible and
then they'll start investing in like a
cool secondhand store and a cool hipster
coffee shop and a vegan restaurant and
then over the course of five or ten
years when the place becomes very cool
they knock down a lot of the buildings
that were there and they start to build
condos something that I've come to call
gentrification condos because they tend
to herald the arrival of people who are
very moneyed into an area where
traditionally it hasn't been people who
are very wealthy and then those
traditional occupants are forced to move
out and go someplace where they can
actually afford to live and a bunch of
people who work in a more moneyed sector
like in technology or energy I'll move
in and go to the hipster coffee shops
and the vegan restaurant
Silicon Valley San Francisco in general
is a great example of this but there's a
lot of different places where this is
happening right now and it's in an
effort in a lot of cases by investors
real estate investors in particular to
take advantage of this unplanned value
gain in certain areas that happens
typically as a result of natural
evolution and cross-pollination of ideas
but they are trying to catalyze that
artificially I learned a term while
researching this episode there is a type
of element that you can add to a city
that you can build into a city when
you're trying to plan it out that allows
you to grow that city and evolve that
city and change that city over time and
the theory behind this is called
tactical urbanism and the idea is that
you essentially work modular elements
like pedestrian bridges and plazas and
arcades and greenbelts they've got a
great Greenbelt
in Atlanta Georgia that goes around the
city and it's built where the old train
line was and that's essentially what
these are these are different elements
that you can either re-appropriate old
infrastructure and turn them into
something new based on the changing
times or you can build a new elements
that adds an additional level sometimes
quite literally an additional level like
a second story or a third story for
pedestrians to walk on and this is all
in an effort to keep a city feeling
livable in order to keep it a place
where people want to live in a lot of
cases the way this is being applied
right now is in cities that have been
built car scale they are building
skyways and pedestrian bridges and
cycling bridges and bike lanes on the
streets in order to allow more people to
walk and bike and interact with each
other and go to that little coffee shop
on the street that nobody would stop at
if they were in a car because there's no
parking
and it's very clever it's a very clever
utilization reutilization rebirth of
these elements and a lot of them the
most popular ones from what I've seen
are the reappropriation so a lot of the
investment is simply in changing
something rather than tearing something
out and putting in something shiny and
new and that allows a city to keep
something of its history while still
allowing it to change with the times to
change as the people living in it change
and that's important really I mean
having a high quality of life in a city
can mean the difference between it being
a thriving culturally sophisticated
neighborhood and being a ghost town we
are cresting the horizon on a whole slew
of new options in terms of communication
transportation construction Commerce
housing so many industries fleets of
autonomous on-demand cars and cheap
sustainable power and building materials
that soak up co2 instead of adding more
to the atmosphere employment
opportunities that don't require a
commute at all they don't require you to
leave your home or your bed dormitory
like shared space apartment complexes
modular and prefab housing 3d printing
which will allow us to potentially print
a lot of things that we would otherwise
go shopping for and urban gardens farm
scrapers farms contained within
skyscrapers which bring fresh food to
urban centers and prevent food deserts
all of these things allow us to spend a
lot less time in transit commuting the
way that we would have in the past the
recent past they allow us to be much
more selective in terms of where we live
so we can choose a lot of the work that
we do and the places that we sleep and
where we spend our time based on our
priorities in terms of culture in the
places that we really enjoy the places
that resonate with us rather than the
places that just happen to be within
commuting distance of the office that we
have
to go sit at these are innovations that
have already and will continue to change
everything about the way that we live
and the way that we work the places we
spend most of our time and who knows
maybe with the right upgrades even the
suburban model could be dragged kicking
and screaming into the present day which
is also the future a planned community
like that might make more sense if we've
got really smart technology built in and
if we build in features that also allow
it to evolve as the people evolve in
their needs evolve but for the moment at
least there's a reason that people
around the world are flooding into
cities at an unprecedented rate and at
the moment because of the current state
of suburbs namely that they tend to suck
I don't see that changing anytime soon
whether you're living out on the
countryside or in a thronging metropolis
I hope you enjoyed this episode of let's
know things if you're digging the show I
would very much appreciate it if you'd
take a second to leave a review on
iTunes or stitcher or wherever you get
your podcasts leaving some stars and
writing up a quick review makes a great
big difference for a new show like this
one and it helps me reach a much larger
audience you can also support the show
by contributing $1 per episode more if
you like but $1 per episode would be
awesome you could find out how to make
such a contribution at let's no thanks
calm or you can purchase one of my books
I've written 30 some-odd books of
different genres and you can find a
complete list of those at Collin dot IO
if you want to receive the free let's
know things newsletter which is sent out
weekly and contains a collection of
links lovingly curated by me you can
subscribe at let's no thanks comm and if
you want to comment on this episode or
share some interesting links of your own
or just say hello pop on over to the lkt
Facebook page at facebook.com slash
let's know things I'm Colin writes thank
you very much for listening
every little thing you think that's me
every little thing you think that you
need every little thing that's just
feeding your green you know I bet that
you'll be fine without every little
feeling that you got ahead
every little thing that you guys you
gotta reach for and you got a grand oh I
bet that you'll be fine without your
team
you